and uh joining us is the snp's leader in
westminster and that's in blackford
hello to you mr blackfoot he's wounded
but he's still standing
well yes but you know kay what a
remarkable uh ton of events yesterday 40
or more than 40 of tory mps voting
against the prime minister having no
confidence in him about two-thirds of
his back ventures and i suppose if you
put it in a wider context the prime
minister now has two-thirds of the
members of the house of commons against
them having no confidence in them
any other person if you look at what
happened to theresa may she went after
losing a no-confidence vote admittedly
after some months but this is about the
man that's in the office of number ten
it's about integrity it's about trust so
it's standards in public life
and the prime minister can try and duck
and dive and try and get out of this but
this is not going away we've got the
privileges committee to come and quite
simply this is a man that has abused the
trust that's been put in him in that
election in 2019 this is not going to go
away and we're left in the situation
that we're talking about him rather than
dealing with the cost of living crisis
the war on ukraine and so on
this man needs to recognize that he has
no moral authority to lead and
ultimately at the end of the day this
man will be gone long before the next
election and the sooner that the
conservative mps recognize that they
have to remove him but then the better
because this is not going to go away as
an issue
yeah but they had an opportunity to do
that mr blackford and they didn't so you
know isn't it is don't you have to
realize the other parties in the house
of commons that he's still there and
he's still our prime minister well the
reason he's there of course is because
of the payroll vote those that are in
the cabinet ministerial office the
private secretaries and so on when
you've got the situation that two-thirds
of your back ventures have voted against
you then franco you're in trouble his
position is not terrible it's not
sustainable and ultimately the prime
minister will go and the sooner that
happens the the better this story is not
over not by a long way and my thoughts
went to remain with all of those that
made so many sacrifices over the coveted
pandemic and the message yesterday from
the prime minister to his own tory mps
that he would do the same thing all over
again that he would go to these leaving
parties he simply doesn't accept that
the rules the lords which the rest of us
have to follow
don't apply to him we cannot have
a leader in the united kingdom that
behaves that way that thinks he's above
the law that thinks it's okay it's
reasonable for him to come and lie as
he's done repeatedly to the house of
commons they've broken as i would allege
the ministerial code and let's not
forget the only prime minister in office
that has been charged and found guilty
of breaking his own laws he simply
should not be in office
yeah the reason he's still there is
because he won with an 80-seat majority
and a lot of mps who are in the comments
would not have been there if it hadn't
been for the charisma of boris johnson
nobody denies that boris johnson won the
election in 2019 but the simple fact is
that he's broken the trust that was put
in him he's abused the position of power
that he's had and it's not just about
party gain it's about everything that
has gone on with this prime minister
that he treats westminster he treats the
house of commons as a personal play
thing everyone is expendable and his
behavior quite simply
is not acceptable i firmly believe that
when we get to the privileges committee
that they will conclude that this prime
minister has broken the ministerial code
and there it is a simple matter that the
prime minister has to be removed from
office so we will go through all the
necessary steps but in the end boris
johnson will pay a price for his
behavior
and the breach of trust that was seen
from him while he's been in office
how far do you think labour will get
today with the hopes of having a clean
up politics vote
well my goodness we do need that don't
we because
you know we have to restore trust and
confidence in public life and
politicians and the behavior of the
prime minister and the fact that he's
still there doesn't help so we need to
make sure that people are accountable
and we need to make sure that the prime
minister can be properly held to account
that there can be references to those
that can hold them to account those that
can adjudicate whether or not he's
broken the ministerial code or not the
fact he is single-handedly trying to
change the rules to make sure that he
can be held from scrutiny really shows
that this is a man that will do anything
to stay in power he'll do anything to
make sure he's not held accountable for
the the lying and the corruption and the
slaves that we've seen from him while
he's been in office
okay but do you think the vote will go
ahead today
uh well i hope there will be a vote
today it's a labour opposition day of
course it doesn't have any force other
than actually showing the
dissent that the house of commons have
from the behavior of this prime minister
but we will certainly be voting against
against the government and any vote that
takes place later today
how long do you think the prime minister
can stay in office
i think he's a dead man walking i think
it's better for all of us that he goes
sooner rather than later i want that day
to be today and i think he needs to
reflect on the lack of support that he
has from his back ventures he needs to
realize that he doesn't have the moral
support he doesn't have the right to
lead his prime minister the sooner he
goes the better
i would like to see the prime minister
offering his resignation to the queen
today